When considering glycolysis,
the conversion of pyruvate
in acetyl-CoA and then the Krebs cycle or the citric acid cycle,
we saw that in some places we were directly receiving ATP,
but we also reduce NAD to NAD.
We said NADN
can later be oxidized
and the energy of oxidation,
which is released by the electrons,
can be used to create ATP.
NADN is the main character here,
but there are other enzymes that play a role.
For example, coenzyme Q. You see it here.
In this video I want to talk about
the process we produce ATP
from the oxidation of these coenzymes.
This process is called
oxidative phosphorylation.
Oxidative phosphorylation.
As we have said, the main character,
when talking about cellular respiration and oxidative phosphorylation
is NAD.
N, O is oxidized
to NAD.
Oxidising
to NAD, which is positively charged.
I often call it NAD +.
If we look at this reaction from a point of view
the oxidation of NADH,
remember - oxidation is a loss of electrons,
we get + and then we have
hydrogen proton,
plus two electrons.
-
This happens when NAD
oxidized to NAD.
This is oxidation here.
I'll do it in another color.
This is the process of oxidation.
If these electrons meet the correct acceptor molecule,
a large amount of energy can be released.
For the ultimate acceptor molecule
of electrons this reaction will be a reduction.
I can show the corresponding reaction.
We have two electrons plus two hydrogen protons.
Or just two protons, the hydrogen nucleus
is a proton, it has no neutrons
in the main hydrogen isotope.
Two protons
plus half a molecule of oxygen.
When we collect all these three
things together,
we will get a molecule of water.
We can assume that oxygen
is the ultimate acceptor of electrons.
Oxygen likes to oxidize
various things,
hence the name of the oxidation process.
And himself
oxygen likes to be reduced.
He likes to take electrons.
Therefore, oxygen is reduced.
Oxygen is reduced.
If we transfer these electrons
directly from NADH to oxygen,
a lot of energy will be released.
So much energy,
that we will not be able to catch most of it.
We will not be able to use it to do useful work.
That is why we have the process of oxidative phosphorylation,
in which the electrons are transferred to the oxygen in a sequence of steps.
The electronics pass
from one electron acceptor to another.
At each pass, some energy is released.
In this way, energy separation is better controlled
and can be used to perform a job.
In this case, work is pumping hydrogen protons
through the membrane and the creation of a gradient,
which will be used to generate ATP.
Let's explain this a little in more detail.
These electrons
will -
I will not go into the slightest detail,
I'll give you an overview of the process.
The electronics will go through different scouts,
will pass from one acceptor to another.
They can be moved
to coenzyme Q then pass
to cytochrome C, continue to pass through different acceptors,
until they finally reach this state here,
they are accepted
from oxygen
and water is obtained.
At each step of this process, energy is emitted.
Energy is released
and as we shall see, it is used
for pumping hydrogen protons
through the membrane. The resulting gradient will be used
for production of ATP.
Let's think about it.
Let's look closely
mitochondria.
It's a mitochondria.
I will paint his
inner membrane.
These are the folds of the inner membrane,
one is called a crystals.
If we talk about many of the folds, we are talking about critics.
We have these folds
in the inner membrane here.
To make it clearer -
this is the outer membrane.
The outer membrane.
This is the inner membrane.
The space between the outer and inner membranes,
this space here,
is called intermembrane space.
Intermembrane
space.
And the space between the inner membrane,
-
this space here is called a matrix.
This is the matrix, the place where it flows
the citric acid cycle or the Krebs cycle.
I will mark it with this sign,
we have here the Krebs cycle.
And this is where most of the NADN is produced.
We also talked about some other coenzymes.
In some textbooks and hours you can hear FAD,
which is reduced to FADN2
during oxidative phosphorylation.
In other cases, it will be associated with an enzyme,
then FADN2
will be used to reduce coenzyme Q to QH2,
which then participates in the oxidative phosphorylation.
It could be any of these two coenzymes.
I will focus on QN2.
Or better to stop at NADN,
because the process is similar.
FADN2 or QN2 participate on
later in the process.
They do not produce so much energy,
but can still be used for the production of ATP.
As we have said, the citric acid cycle,
for which we have spoken in previous videos,
flows into the matrix.
We will now look at it closer.
If we look at this part closely,
I will use this color to be visible.
Let's take a look here,
here is this crease from the inner membrane.
Let's make clear,
like any membrane,
it is a dual phospholipid layer.
I will use the same color
like this one
of the chart.
We have
double layer of phospholipids.
Obviously, my drawing is not in real scale.
Almost ready.
Another clarification.
We have enzymes,
which pass through the phospholipid double layer.
These enzymes,
these protein complexes help
oxidative phosphorylation.
This sequence of enzymes,
this sequence of proteins is called
electron transport chain.
I will draw it.
Let's say it's a protein.
I'll draw them a little abstractly.
We can accept the electron transport chain as
these proteins or as
the process by which the electrons move from one acceptor to another,
to reach the ultimate acceptor - oxygen.
This may be a protein,
and this is another.
I will draw only a few,
this is a very quick review
of the process.
This is very simple
presentation.
Let's say that at first
NAD is coming
-
and lends its protons and electrons,
turning it into NAD +.
Oxidising.
These electrons are taken up by the acceptor molecule,
then passed on to another acceptor
and the next one.
When passing electrons through the electron transport chain
energy is released,
which is used to pump hydrogen protons from the matrix,
on this side, the left side here,
this is the matrix.
Here goes the citric acid cycle.
We have protons pumped out,
these protons are pumped out,
when releasing energy
of the electron transfer from one acceptor molecule
to another.
Electrons move from higher energy states
to lower, releasing energy
and moving towards ever more electronegative acceptors.
They feel more comfortable with water,
than with NADH.
When moving, the electrons
-
pass
from a higher energy system to a lower one.
We create this proton gradient,
so the concentration of protons
on the right side of the membrane--
This is this country.
This space is here
intermembrane space,
where the concentration of water protons increases.
Here we have a reserve of energy, as it represents
electrochemical gradient. All these positive charges
are repelled,
want to get to the less positive matrix here.
Furthermore, because here we have a higher concentration of hydrogen protons,
we will also have diffusion.
Protons will want to move in the direction of their concentration gradient
to the matrix.
There are fewer protons there.
There are fewer protons in the matrix,
than
in the intermembrane space.
This is the cell's ability to use this energy,
to produce ATP.
To see how this happens,
I'll draw some more of the membrane
in another color.
In that part of the membrane
we have a protein,
called ATP synthase.
ATP synthase is actually a protein complex.
It functions as an enzyme
and passes through the membrane.
It is a remarkable molecule.
I will make a clearer chart after a while.
We can see that ATP synthase passes through the membrane.
Its mechanical structure is very important.
We have a dent
and an axis located therein.
It seems like that.
You can imagine,
that part
keeps everything together.
The enzyme passes through the membrane.
I'll show you a better chart.
The membrane continues and from now on, of course.
The membrane continues.
The important thing is that hydrogen protons
can move in the direction of their concentration gradient
via the ATP synthase.
They can stop the axle from rotating.
I will draw it like that.
They make the axle spin,
moving in the direction
of its electrochemical gradient.
This axis rotates, but it is not smooth.
Not made of metal,
but from amino acids,
will be rugged.
It seems like that.
Thanks to this APPL
can be retained here.
Let's say this is ADP and then we have a phosphate group.
In fact, there are three different places to which
this can happen.
This is ADP, and this is a phosphate group.
There is another place, but I will not paint it.
When this turns,
the conformation of the protein is changing
and the phosphate group is pushed into the ADP,
but energy is needed to get stuck
and to form ATP.
When forming ATP,
are no longer attached to the active center
and are released.
So we have
this mechanical motor.
We can treat it as a water turbine.
The water passes through it and its energy
is used to generate electricity.
Here the hydrogen protons pass
in the direction of its concentration gradient,
the internal movement they cause helps the meeting
of the phosphate groups and the ADP molecules in which ATP is formed.
This is the way ATP is produced.
I'll show another visualization
of the ongoing processes,
to better understand what's going on in your body at this point.
These processes take place in your body,
otherwise we would not be able to talk.
This is the way we produce energy.
Here we have a more accurate image
of the ATP synthase.
Let's do some extra
the inscriptions on this chart.
-
It is hard to paint on it.
Let's see.
This part here,
this area is
intermembrane space.
This is it
the matrix.
This membrane is a dual phospholipid layer.
I can draw the double layer of phospholipids
right here.
This is the inner membrane
or fold the inner membrane,
this is a crystal.
Hydrogen protons accumulate
in the intermembrane space,
thanks to the electron transport chain.
So now they can pass
in the direction of its electrochemical gradient.
This rotates the rotor,
causing the production of ATP.
We have ADP
plus a phosphate group,
what ATP gives us.
It is unbelievable that all this
it flows in your cells,
while we talk.
This is not an abstract process, torn apart
from reality.
In fact, this process makes reality possible.
I hope you appreciate it all better now.
We spent a lot of time
in talks about cell breathing.
We talked a lot about ATF production.
We can produce ATF directly
by glycolysis,
but most energy
comes from the reduction of these coenzymes
especially by reducing NAD to NAD
and thanks to oxidative phosphorylation
and the electron transport chain.
We use the oxidation of NADH,
to pump protons from the matrix
to the intermembrane space.
Then these protons return to the matrix
via the ATP synthase, which
attaches phosphate groups to the ADP to obtain an ATP.
ATP is the biological currency for energy.